okay so here we are here's another
episode of eating your feed so we have
both been on here before yeah I saw you
boil the peach that was pretty neat
who knew peaches look like that yeah I
have no idea what I was doing in there
if I'm gonna be forced to make this show
Adam this is gonna be a little bit of a
weird one we're gonna do this thing
called it Tim pond Oh
basically it looks like this stretched
animal skin over a bucket of meats
pasta sauces eggs go in there that's
kind of crazy and then you kind of fold
that dough over and you bake the whole
thing off we've seen it on this show
called binging with babish awesome Food
Show online
he made it based on one of my favorite
movies called big night New York Times
did a version chef I love David Chang
hosted his own version on Instagram
recently whoa it's crazy yeah so as
always we're going to bring on Rea I
think we're not gonna make our own fresh
pasta except for the shell we'll make
our own meatballs sauce Italian sausages
stuffed shells anything that we should
look out for make us saw that game
applause this is the biggest pot that we
have available to us here at tasty right
now I think I want to go a little bit
bigger than this sure we'll make a real
thick one with two seeds so we're gonna
go get our stuff now
thing boom look at that alright let's
get started yeah you do the tomato sauce
in this and I'm gonna take this guy and
fire off the mushroom ragout I'm ready
to get into the paste the paste face
right you're making the tomato sauce
yeah why do I call it paste I don't know
I'm just google searching BuzzFeed
tomato sauce I'm gonna start cutting an
onion up oh yeah it's the one time I get
to cry so my mushroom recipe I don't
think I bought all the right ingredients
for any one particular recipe so I'm
just kind of making it up and combining
a bunch of them hot spaghetti but we're
never doing that right now yeah and we
gotta worry about that
get the honker parm you don't think you
need that we don't leave them at the
farm either cut this up great thank you
put it in the pot yes with when it's hot
and then the other goes in it we're good
that's it
how much butter do I need I don't know
so I'm just gonna chop this in half this
is what are you doing there right yeah
chopping this up so you take your knife
and you cut almost all the way through
each of these is a distinct strand like
that so when I cut this way then you got
a little queue you ready for this
pinching it together you go boom and now
look at that this is the shape of your
onion next we're gonna do garlic all
right where's our sink it's in the other
room it's like most kitchens it's in the
other room
[ __ ] egg salt more mushrooms how's it
going pal we're getting there man I'm
going to add a little bit of tomato
paste gonna add an e in chobe and then
I'm gonna deglaze that with brandy okay
it smells really fishy putting up our
tomatoes your mom so much stuff to go
ahead look at that this is weird I'll
tell you what is it okay so we have
olive oil salt pepper onion and garlic
and carrot try and get that umami flavor
right I'm throw some rosemary in my
mushroom ragout here cuz why not you
know and then pretty soon we're gonna
my anchovies here I'm really trying to
make this look cool next add the crushed
red pepper flakes in the tomato paste
such color I swear that's my first bull
of wagon let it spill over don't stop
pouring tip it and keep going I love the
double steam columns we got coming off
over there you know it's like our two
turntables like Daft Punk
Tomatoes meting fish sauce to this I
think it's just gonna add like a smack
of depth to it like you won't even know
it's there
okay I mean I trust you alright so I'm
happy with where the mushroom ragout is
at for now you want to bite Adam
delicious there's no comparison there I
mean this whole no no no yeah yeah we're
gonna be talking about your sauce more
than the heck out of here now we're
gonna make some meatballs this is a
hilariously large bowl we got a ground
beef here and our ground pork throwing
some onion in here crack two eggs right
in there cheese Angie's I like a pretty
green my meatballs no preemptively add
some breadcrumbs how do you recall
buying that I slipped it in at the last
moment you splash your milk in here all
right start squeezing those around you
got oh I mean I love what you added in
here last minute the milk the other
thing that I can't remember it I'll
start rolling these up oh that's a big
meatball you know what that's okay he's
a big boy boom that's a trade meatballs
if I ever seen them oh okay I'll just
wash my heads it's okay and so these
guys are going in end of day one
mushroom ragout is done we got our
tomato sauce oh we got to pull our
meatballs out of the oven yeah the whole
thing I am giddy with joy right now I'm
happy that you're excited quite honestly
I might wear suit tomorrow on so like I
want to impress this meal let's invite
Rea on to check out what's been going on
all day yeah it's so good okay so
today's the big day you got to cook our
pasta we're gonna make stuffed shells
cook our sausages and make boiled eggs
great we also have to make the whole
crust so we've got our sausages here I'm
just gonna three hot three mild
these are hefty we're just gonna bake
these
this recipe comes from the binging with
babish video we're just gonna use his
recipe for the crust to ensure that we
have enough dough to fill our Tim pond
oh and I'm just asked if service area
goes up proportionally to volume I just
don't know where to start with that
question is it safe to assume that we
should just increase the recipe by 50%
yeah just do it and like see what's
gonna happen so we're gonna do 30 ounces
of double zero flour four whole eggs and
12 V Oakes I'm actually really bad at
cracking eggs okay see we're gonna have
a bad time here
oh I'm cracking I'm cracking it's going
in it then that was 11 here's well do
you want some egg whites maybe somebody
wants this for lunch so we're just gonna
pour out our dough make a little well
for our eggs in a little squirt of salt
I'm gonna add a little bit of olive oil
okay oh god this is a boy I don't do
this right boy why it's wrong oh no
nothing nothing is wrong it's okay it's
there let's just go for it there's
nothing back now can't control Z this
moment yeah okay that feels great Oh God
somebody check the sausages all right
our sausage is cooked so the dough feels
pretty dry so we're gonna add an egg get
some more moisture in there try to get
this thing together we're totally in the
dark here you know at some point I'll be
out of this but right now it sucks and I
cannot see the light so last time we did
a bad job of making sure all the eggs
were incorporated before trying to get
all the flour together so we're gonna
just make another batch but tackle it in
two separate smaller batches Ray's gonna
help with one of them think like you
gonna use a little by little yeah all
right this looks like fun so I'm gonna
get started yeah that's great
sometimes you know like depends on the
types of egg maybe he's using logic and
our egg it's like small it's extremely
sticky I don't know how you did this
this makes a whole lot more sense I can
already see why this is the way you do
it yeah oh that's beautiful
we don't suck eggs are about done next
we're gonna be making some Dumbo shells
I'm gonna make the filling for the
stuffed shells now I'm gonna like kind
of make it up I want ricotta mozzarella
parmesan some herbs maybe a squeeze of
lemon
and yeah that's it writing it up a
little bit that lemon brighten it up
oops geez look at that it was like
applesauce mm-hmm let's start boiling
some pasta what else could I sneak in
here apostle spoons what is a pasta
rigatoni pot looking hot all right I'm
gonna start filling shells never done
this before it's basically a savory
cannoli oh sorry
I might be over filling them slightly so
oh nice job with these eggs oh my god
just rolling your hands through a bunch
of eggs if I words like a music video I
would be like so the concept is
hard-boiled eggs in a bathtub and first
gonna go crazy all right all right all
right
campano dole roll out this is one of the
most satisfying yeah looking things
unclear whether we have enough dough I
think it'll be fine it's gonna line it
our Dutch oven with butter and olive oil
we're gonna start rolling this thing on
oh okay let's get the pot in hot I'm
gonna gently push it into the sides
right nice all right you want to start
scooping rigatoni sure almost half of
the pasta didn't make a dent I'm worried
about how much stuff we have let's grate
some of that cheese right into there
heck arena Romano Ray Romano I'm gonna
start doing meatballs now I think we
should split them in a half just so that
we get an even layer of them let's do a
little bit of tomato sauce smell oh yeah
I want to see like an even blanket of
that
oh we're gonna run out of space actually
soft-shells next okay are we gonna have
enough I really hope so we'll just kind
of do a little bit of cheese along the
sides here fill it out a little bit we
have the sausages all right let's just
fill in these cracks with eggs right
okay we'll just have a couple leftover
eggs first ones gonna have a really eggy
part of the yeah there's no way this
won't taste good no grading a little
more pecorino on there now we're just
having fun I feel like Bob Ross
leftovers we have three eggs one
meatball and like a quarter cup of pasta
how should we fold this together oh I
gotta try one so am i doing standing
here
oh my god that's like a solid 45 pounds
all right let's get this bad boy in the
oven yeah okay it's been about 50
minutes to an hour we're gonna take the
lid off
maybe we shouldn't put the butter on top
it's too Brown it's getting Brown a
little early we're gonna burn I don't
know an hour and a half in on the tempeh
no bake a little bit concern about the
Browning happening on top so we put some
foil which I think will help deflect the
heat I'm gonna go on the record as
saying I think a little danger adds a
lot of excitement to a meal it's been
over two hours now yes oh it's perfect
it's great we're gonna call that done
we're going to unmold it
tell me put it out all right here comes
no hesitation
oh yeah that looks perfect I just want
to stand here in famine mm-hmm pull down
already we can eat it now come on
everybody gather round for this feast
Wow all right let's get in there with a
knife I'd support you okay give you my
proxy one
oh it's juicy here we go boy oh boy okay
the moment of truth you guys ready for
this yeah there it is yeah I cannot
believe it I swear to God if this falls
on the ground Cheers
earlier in the video I drink from a bowl
yeah make it rain that's the temp on Oh
[Applause]
mmm holy crap yeah for real I think this
is the best thing you've ever made ray
gives it its blessing I'll probably
leave the eggs out yeah yeah I don't
know why the eggs are there I don't know
why it's great that ragout is just out
of the world yeah that's gonna happen
with the tempeh no I think it was a
great success
Thank You babish I wouldn't not make it
again I would love to make this together
you kidding me this would be fun yeah
it's great so just too much work
[Music]
you